in this 2016 election cycle there seems
to be one foolproof way to rally voters
on the right
I think Islam HS well he's certainly the
loudest islamaphobe Trump isn't the only
one bashing Muslims for political gain
for a long time negative portrayals of
Muslims was part of our media landscape
but the post 9/11 Bush era of us versus
them paved the way for some serious
llama phobia in the 2008 presidential
election America's first black president
faced racists birthers racist birthers
but nothing was quite as politically
damaging as the M word even Hillary
Clinton who was vying for the Democratic
nomination at the time was accused of
spreading rumors that Obama was a Muslim
her campaign got a lot of heat for
allegedly releasing this 2006 picture of
Obama's visit to Kenya to reinforce
those fears after Obama won the
nomination a concerned voter approached
the Republican candidate John McCain
saying that she heard that Obama was an
Arab his response no ma'am no ma'am he's
a he's a he's a decent family man
citizen because Arabs and Muslims can't
be good family men or Americans at that
but the Obama campaign's response to all
of this was almost as troubling as the
accusations themselves deny and distance
without ever really defending Muslims at
a rally in Detroit Obama campaign
volunteers even borrowed to Muslim women
wearing hijab from sitting behind the
candidate so that they wouldn't be seen
on camera the campaign apologized but
the action was telling like most at the
time Obama lacked the political courage
to stand up and say I'm not a Muslim but
so what if I was in fact virtually the
only person to say that was former
Secretary of State Colin Powell who
wasn't even in office at that point the
really right answer is what if he is is
there something wrong with being a
Muslim in this country
the answer's no that's not America fast
forward to today sure the president
finally visited an American mosque in
his last year in office and Hillary
setting herself apart from Trump is now
vocal in her defense of Muslim Americans
making sure that Muslim Americans
don't feel left out or marginalized but
the 2008 presidential election cemented
the idea that Muslim is a slur something
to be feared or an accusation to be
denied and not part of America given all
the free-flowing Islamophobia that
wasn't properly called out back then are
we really surprised to be hearing this
now wait problem in this country
it's called Muslims we know our current
president is one really no he's not even
an American we need this is mindless